that's exactly it's kind of a roller
coaster the last couple weeks has been
just like that but I think today as of
right now feeling pretty cozy and
content getting up on the stage with the
energy tonight is probably gonna be them
it's great but it's gonna be really good
we're just excited to share that energy
with the crowd tonight yeah this is
definitely a celebration I mean no it's
not you know people you know may have
moments of sadness but this is this is
you know to celebrate
the awesomeness that was Mike Taylor
he's here with us literally and
figuratively we've got his key setup
that he that he plays set up right on
stage with some candles on it and we
certainly feel him with us and we're
gonna we're gonna honor him what's
gotten you through the last couple of
weeks oh it's been like the most solid
kind of comfort you've had it's hard to
say death is such a strange thing as I'm
sure anyone who's experienced it I think
being together is really important and
sharing memories once you get to once
you get past kind of the initial shock
it's nice to be able to share memories
and just kind of I mean for me putting
the show together has been a very big
distraction and just trying to make it
as amazing as we possibly can to honor
the legacy of the beer guy because he
was a real true friend and a brother to
ask me so we just I guess for the last
couple weeks
been prepping for this day and trying to
make it right yeah and all the the
support from the community and her fans
and Friends just like seeing messages
and stuff that really helps you helps
you through it it really does yeah he
touched more people than we ever could
have imagined lives
in his time and to hear from those
people and hear those little stories
flowing in is incredible to us we knew
we knew him as our bandmate and as our
as our brother of course but to hear the
little stories from fans or from friends
of his colleagues of his how many people
who touch is incredible and if we can
share that and celebrate that tonight
then of course we're gonna do that
are you comfortable talking about what
happened or maybe getting us an infinite
did you see this coming at all or no
absolutely not this was it was natural
causes and really for us it's kind of
just a reminder of how precious of a
gift life really is and that you know
you just kind of need to live every day
as if it's your last because to just
never really know what can happen
he was as fit as a thirty year old man
he shouldn't you know he should have
been with us a lot longer
what's one lasting member you want to
share about like he was he didn't get a
chance to show his humor a lot as beard
guy because he you know didn't say he
was a his character was a man of few
words but in real life he was he was
kind of a jokester of the party he had
very very witty responses for every
every situation so and yeah those are
kind of my memories of him yeah he was
really kind
a really kind of man like you you know
you see him as beard guy and you see him
as the stoic character that he was
really warm and caring and he had a he
had a different relationship with each
and every single one of us and I just
had so many memories just a goofball to
like I like what she and Sarah were
saying he he'd really embodied this
stoic character that the internet sort
of made made him into and loved that so
much but I like the guy would just like
bust into falsetto out of nowhere and
play ridiculous show tunes on his piano
and it just just was such a beacon of
positivity and light for all of us and
and we're gonna miss him a lot and so
going forward what you guys gonna do to
keep his legacy alive and keep that
beard got spirit in the band I mean yeah
we we're gonna carry on with our world
tour and we're kind of gonna bring the
spirit of this event and this Memorial
kind of on the road without with us to
the fans around the world that can't be
here today and yeah we just want to
honor him in the show as much as we can
and we're gonna have to figure that out
still but we have you know we're gonna
work hard at doing that it's not gonna
be easy
it's a it's there's no replacing this
guy but we think that there's a right
way and we've had the blessing of his
family to to carry forth and to carry
him with us in the right way and make
sure we're honoring him and his family
and of course honoring our fans who have
used our music and had our music with
them through their hard times and now
it's it's it's our time to to rely on
our fans to get us through our hard
times so today one thing fans
to show what's what were you hoping to
send across today for I'm just we want
to show the camaraderie in the music
industry and kind of spread that to the
rest of the people to our fans and to
you know the people that are gonna be
here today and we have a lot of great
friends and great acts you know donating
their time and a lot of amazing
businesses and the City of Burlington
and sound music festival just donating
all of their time and resources to this
and that's kind of I think it's just a
vibe of camaraderie and community yeah
we also wanted to give the fans a chance
to you know attend some kind of memorial
for him because there were a couple
different sides you know when you're as
iconic and big as somebody like that
there's the smaller family side and then
there's a whole other world that we
really want wanted to bring all of them
together so that they had a chance again
to like attended a memorial of some kind
and to celebrate hand and show their
love so yeah I understand that you guys
are partnered with music counts I
believe too - happy
it might become a bit like that yeah he
loved you know helping kids and and and
and and being involved in youth in the
community and that was a charity that
like really reached out but that he felt
was something that he could get behind
and he always was pushing it anywhere we
went and we knew it meant a lot to him
and if if you don't know anything about
it it basically you know gets
instruments in the hands of kids across
Canada in communities that might not
have the resources to have those
programs and he's you know he's a strong
believer in the power of music and how
it can help people in their lives so
that was something that's close to him
so we're gonna be you know donating a
lot to them and and if anyone wants to
donate on behalf of him you can just go
to their website music count ca and
there's a page set up for him there
anything you want to say to your fans
who've been with you of course for all
these years especially in the last
couple weeks I'm sure with the
outpouring of messages and I just
overall support had just a huge thank
you and and that it means a lot and you
know we will do whatever we can to repay
them for the support they've shown us
and yeah I mean there's there's fans
that have been flying out to this event
some of our you know fans that have been
with us forever and it's it's crazy that
that we have the opportunity to do this
so yeah yeah we owe it to them we owe it
to Mike to carry forward and we're gonna
do that and do it in the right way and
and we look forward to to carrying the
torch in his honor
like super super close I mean they just
do all this work together and seem to
all be very close friends how do you
rely on each other have you been
supportive for each other yes big time
yeah we have I mean we're family so
that's what families do
yeah I know you guys are working this
got held in today as well and having
other people be part of this what does
that mean for you guys
yeah well as johnny was saying the
camaraderie like within the music
industry can be so powerful and the
artists that we're gonna be onstage with
today are all people who you buy their
collaborated with or people that we've
gone on tour with and it's pretty
amazing you know just want you that
they're just still one phone call away
you could become the best of friends on
the road and then not see each other for
five months and then you know call it
Scotty hey Scotty we're doing a video
and he right away yeah I mean like it's
just so you know when we were kind of
laying out and deciding on the musicians
that we wanted to bring in for this
event he was definitely the first one on
our list and and everybody else has just
shown like an incredible amount of
support so it really is it's pretty
magical the the family that you get when
you've toured or make videos or done
collaborations with different artists
yeah there's a testament to not only
being a part of their music industry and
part of like the musical collective but
specifically in Canada already have that
in a way it's kind of a small family but
also it is like this expanded family
you can as you say it kind of call at
each other and be supportive of each
other how each other think it talks
about it yeah absolutely anything else
you guys want to share with your fans
while you're here just that you left
them nothing a lot and we really
appreciate their support through this
time too and to everybody who's shown
love for this event and showing love for
Mike beard guy Taylor and put the music
you